you almost wouldn't be surprised if like
something suddenly swam by you know
[Music]
hello and welcome back to edible history
the show that brings to life the
culinary creations of past generations
today we're in for a brewed awakening as
we explore the history behind the making
of me when I hear Mead I think of old
kings and queens toasting and drinking
something out of goblets with huge
turkey legs and hands but what is the
meeting of mead to find out I'm talking
with Julia Skinner a food historian
author and fermentation specialist hey
Julia thanks for being here so today
we're gonna be talking about making Mead
how far back does me bacon go tell us
about me tell us about me for drinking
this is their daily Mead and that is why
they say the Scottish Highland warriors
were so formidable is because they were
drinking all the stuff that was like a
protein drink into their psyche Oh super
strong how do people know that what they
were drinking wasn't gonna poison them
[Music]
so can you tell us a bit about the
recipes we'll be making today the first
one
[Music]
thank you so much for offering your your
wisdom your expertise your guidance now
it's time to satisfy our need for Mead
[Music]
we're actually going to be making two
recipes one from 77c e ancient Rome now
this recipe only has two ingredients
which is why we're making two recipes
for this it is recommended that
rainwater should be stored for five
years since we live in California we
don't really have that much rainwater
laying around let alone rainwater that's
been stored for five years so to fill
this we're gonna go ahead and use a nice
distilled water first things first let's
boil 9 cups of water now that our water
is almost at a boil it's time to add our
honey oh this is three cups of pure raw
honey the recipe calls for one part
honey to three parts water so if you're
making your own version at home that's
how it works
well we've blended our honey and water
and now it's time to store plenty says
keep the mixture in the Sun for 40 days
after the rising of the dog star
basically the recipe is saying leave it
for 40 days out in the hot hot Sun or
others pour it off after 9 days and then
cork it up so we're going for the nine
day method and that's it now it's time
to pour in store
why did that happen
[Music]
Wow and that's the easy one gonna seal
the deal here we go
wipe off any little fits we've got our
Mead hot and sealed and ready to go do
we have a place I can store this for
nine days
[Music]
our next recipe comes from England in
1669 it is a receipt for meat this
recipe of course has water and honey but
it also calls for parsley fennel cloves
and the addition of a least we'll get to
that first things first let's add our
honey to water wow that's a lot of honey
I bet honey is the mead of bees
nutritious delicious and maybe they're
all slightly buzzed next we turn up the
heat and bring it all to a boil alright
that looks pretty well mixed together so
we're gonna leave it to boil and now
prepare our vegetables
[Music]
so here can you see this right look at
that little parsley Wow just your
standard regular parsley huh oh my god
that's the part we're gonna be using so
we're gonna shave it slice it and set it
aside now since we're going off the
assumption they didn't have proper
peelers we're gonna be using a spoon to
gently coax the skin off the parsley so
now that we've successfully filled our
parsley we're gonna slice off the top
and bottom and then cut them on a little
bit of a bias all right now that we've
prepped the last of our parsley it's
time to fillet our fennel so this is
fennel to cut our fennel we'll be
chopping off the tops then we're gonna
cut down the center from here we're
gonna slice out the heart of the fennel
nice nice whoa mmm that smells like
licorice
if celery and liquorice had a baby it
would be fennel from here we're gonna
make some pretty thin slices to maximize
our fennel flavor once we finish up our
fennel it'll be time to add it to our
meat I gotta say I hope these flavors
aren't too mediocre
now that we finished with our fennel
it's time to add it to our hot little
pot of Mead it's like we're making a
weird sweet soup as you can tell there's
a lot of scum on the surface of this
meat our honey is pretty raw pretty
natural pretty organic so naturally it
looks gross the recipe says next to skim
it very well so we want to get as much
of this scum off the top as we can
all right we've skimmed off the last of
our scum there's a lot so we're gonna
put it aside and never think about it
again all right so we're gonna take this
little brew baby off the heat set it
aside and let it cool for about a day
nay night so now that our brew baby has
had a day to rest it's time to add the
last of the ingredients the recipe says
to do a very few cloves pounded and put
in a linen cloth I'm gonna take the
interpretation of very few to mean three
one two we're gonna take our cloves put
them in the center and then pound them
using the flat side of our mallet I've
been looking forward to this all day
went by so fast next we're going to
create a small linen satchel to put our
clothes in our brew we pinch these up we
pinch these up and we pinch these up you
can make a satchel any way it pleases
yet just as long as it works
and voila then we just plop it into our
brew whoo look at that scum free beauty
wow it really smells like vaguely
fermenting honey must be working next to
add to the fermentation we'll be using a
new good barm aka ale yeast whoa I gotta
tell ya ha that a least combined with
the already fragrant scent of the ice is
a bit of a stinky process isn't it we're
gonna give it a mix but it's not going
to incorporate completely that's okay
next it's time to store our brew in this
cute little pot bits and all
now if you're wondering when I'm gonna
take out all the chunky bits surprise
I'm not we're using a really wide mouth
vessel because all of these just slowly
fermenting parts are what makes the
flavor so good we're almost at the
bottom of our bucket here I'm just gonna
pour off the last little bit of it Lord
knows we want to save all this good good
vinegar juice YUM and finally the recipe
says and within a fortnight it will be
ready to drink but if it stay longer it
will be the better so don't be too
finicky about time don't make much a
brew about nothing time to go meet your
brew brother no oh you're heavier not
that I'm trying to compare you do that
would be unhealthy one fortnight later
we're back our brew babies have had some
time to rest and do their dirty dirty
magic so we're gonna start with plenties
need because it's the most simple you
know so let's start simple first we're
gonna open it maybe we'll take a little
sniff you know see what we're in for
if honey was a foot we're gonna be using
our funnel and bottling our Mead nice
one bottle of Plenty's Mead good to go
next this one let's open her up oh it
has a certain sour ripeness to it I
wasn't quite expecting
it's definitely thicker as a liquid then
I thought it would be this doesn't look
like something I want to put in my body
we've got our pun ease we've got our
meat and now it's time to see which of
these is the least bad I'm gonna go
ahead and guess the Plenty's will be
better because it's simpler this is the
plenties yep strong fragrance of honey
and now for the meat you know I've never
even had me
maybe I'll love it maybe I will think
it's great let's go Anna yummy yum-yum
this will make me strong like a Scottish
warrior
you know it's just very sweet I actually
can see how it might get better with
time look I like honey I don't drink it
but if as a drinking honey sure it's
great let's not forget this recipe is
from 77c II so frankly to be able to
taste it at all that's really cool our
meat comes from about 1,600 years later
so it's probably been improved upon
bottoms up
[Music]
you know it very much tastes like
little cupboard would fit you ever go
out have one too many sugary drinks head
home and then they all come back
yeah after that I could drink plenty all
day I definitely don't necessarily think
I'm a Mead person
remember that time we had the duck fat
french fries that was great and now
we're here both meats have a very like
fortifying quality and that I feel
really in touch with my body right now
you know like whoo like yeah I
definitely see how drinking this would
make you be like thank you for watching
arguably one of our most memorable
episodes of my drunk kitchen
I feel like this stuff makes me feel
drunk and that's a wrap on season 2 of
edible history thank you so much for
watching if you've loved watching edible
history make sure you share it all
across your social media and let us know
what you want to see in season 3 bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]